Great is just been to India on holiday and he's shown me some
terrific pictures and video of the Taj Mahal.
I've never been there immediately when he showed me that I could see
that the building is being cleaned. And when you think about cleaning,
you think about chemistry.
The Taj Mahal is famous because it's white and it's white
because it's made of white marble. For years and years,
there has been a problem that the white marble gets dirty and it keeps on
getting dirty and they keep on having to clean it.
Why is the Taj Mahal dirty? How do you know what the dirt is?
How'd you get rid of it?
I looked around and I couldn't find any completely white marble,
but I found this lump of marble here,
which is a reasonable piece of carved marble.
Rather like the things that you might find in the Taj Mahal, the of course,
a different style and what's more, it's dirty. Then it was in our house.
That's why I found it. And it's been laying in the fireplace in our house.
So it's got quite a lot of dirt and dust on it.
The first thing about a marble,
which I can show you is that some dust you could rub off quite
easily with a brush, although it's quite tedious,
you can brush even the Taj Mahal.
So there's some dirt like the dirt here, which brushing doesn't remove.
So the question is, how do you find that what it is?
I found a really quite interesting scientific paper that was published
two years ago,
where they actually solve this problem of finding out what the dirt was.
The problem is that the Taj Mahal is a huge building.
You can't very easily climb up with microscopes or
spectrometers high on the walls, but these authors had a really clever idea.
They took small pieces of marble,
essentially the same material that the Taj Mahal is made of and glued
it to the walls in various places,
and then left it a few months and took it back to the lab and looked at the
surface on what they found was that even after short time,
the surface became slightly colored and it was due to particles,
very small particles, not more than three microns in diameter,
that's three millions of a meter and they were essentially particles of carbon.
Now, you know, we always like to do experiments on periodic videos.
And for once I can do an experiment or try to do one in my
office, I'm not going to do it on my precious piece of marble,
but here we've got a piece of limestone,
which is very similar to marble in chemically it's calcium carbonate.
So what I'm going to do is to light the candle.
If some of you have watched a Halloween candle video,
you will know that out of the top of candle, flame,
you get sooty particles and I'm going to just try passing
it underneath.
[Inaudible].
No, the first thing to say that what I've done is equivalent to
centuries of the Taj Mahal being exposed to the atmosphere.
But you know, we'd like to accelerate things for you.
So what we now have is a mixture of carbon particles and some
waxy oily solid. Now, if you go back to Brady's amazing pictures,
the clean parts are strikingly white,
and some parts are slightly yellow.
Brady described it as rather like old paper,
but this is is black because I cheated and used a really
powerful source of carbon on the small area,
in the case of the Taj Mahal. And in particular,
the atmosphere of Agra, there are particles of carbon in the air,
but their density is quite low and they land every so often on the
surface. And gradually as the layer builds up,
it will tend to change color. It will begin very pale yellow,
and then probably get darker and darker as the layers build up. Now,
I'm not going to discuss in great detail the origins of the air
pollution, but at least some of it comes from vehicle exhausts.
The gas is coming out or unburned particles coming out to the back of cars and
lorries.
So now the authorities at the Taj Mahal have
banned vehicles with internal combustion engines from quite a large
radius round
and Brady and the others tourists have to make little
journeys in sort of electric golf, buggies,
or the equivalent to do the final half mile or so to get there,
to try and keep the air a bit cleaner around it.
Of course there are other emissions from industrial plants nearby,
and they're also emissions from people burning fuel
such as co down. So it's a big mixture of sources,
but the real problem is how do you get it off the stone?
What you have is a fairly thin surface covering of this
dirt, which you could in principle scrape off,
but that would damage the surface of the marble.
So next time it will get harder to remove.
And every time it'll get harder and harder, somehow you've got to use chemicals.
The problem is that marble is calcium carbonate,
which is very sensitive for acid.
Even the acid that comes from industrial emissions are enough to
damage the surface.
So you've got to use something that chemically is very neutral
or even slightly alkaline. So in fact, the authorities at times,
Mahal have used a method, which is in fact,
I think quite a traditional method,
which is based on the way that people in the old days used
to treat wool. Now, fortunately,
I don't need to produce a sample of seeps will because you can
see quite a good simulation here.
But in the old days,
the people who cleaned up wool we're called folders.
And they used a mineral called folders earth,
which on one hand removed particles of dirt and stuff,
sticking to the surface of the sheep's wool.
It also removed the last vestiges of oil
and grease from the wall and also made the wall rather than denser.
This is a sort of clay which goes into very fine
particles and those particles are very good.
It's absorbing combination of dirt and oil.
If you mix it with water,
it forms of paste like mud.
So you can put it on the surface of the stone, like a mud pack.
And after a day or two,
it dries and cracks as it dries,
it becomes very flaky and you can just brush it off.
You can remove the carbon particles from the surface. Very gently.
Clay are quite complicated,
mixtures of very fine particles and minerals that are based on Allie
minium and alkaline metals like sodium potassium and calcium.
The key point is that they are ionic compounds.
The aluminium has often had,
will have hydroxyl groups or H groups on the surface,
particularly if you made it into a slurry with water,
but because the particles are so small,
each gram of material will have a very high surface area.
And therefore it means there is a big surface to attract the carbon
particles of the marble.
And you don't need an enormous difference in the attraction between the surface
of the marble and the Fuller's earth,
because you're leaving the mud pack on for a period of some days.
And that slight difference is enough to remove most of the particles.
And again, you don't have to remove them all,
but the more you remove the cleaner, the marble will look,
I think it's really nice that you can use the same material to
clean cheap fleeces to clean the Taj Mahal.
But the important thing is that these materials were
identified over a period of centuries, if not thousands of years.
So they have probably some of the best natural materials you can
get because people have tried so many and found that this is the best
I am in India, in Mumbai.
What used to be called Bombay and behind me is the famous tans,
my whole hotel. And when I'm in India, of course,
I begin to think about Indian chemistry, Indian science,
I'm on Bondai beach in Sydney, Australia.
And I want to talk to you about ozone because there's an interesting paper.
That's just been published.